it's almost impossible not to be excited
by the new trailer for rogue one I'm
Kate and this is your queue news update
rogue one which is set to come out on
December 16 2016 is set before the
original Star Wars and focuses upon a
group of mercenaries who are hired to
catch the plans to the Death Star it is
directed by Godzilla's gareth edwards
and stars Felicity Jones Diego Luna Riz
Ahmed Donnie Yen Ben Mendelsohn forest
whitaker and Mads Mikkelsen in a recent
interview with movieweb armored revealed
that robe one would provide a different
experience to pass Star Wars movies what
Gareth is bringing to rogue one is
incredible organic loose kind of a raw
feeling the actor said when he speaks
about rogue one he speaks about it in
terms of a war movie and he compares it
to other war movies what it will bring
is a fresh pair of eyes on a familiar
world I think that is real exciting
we're doing something a little different
the other films and hopefully people are
ready for that and will embrace it so
did you like the rogue one trailer or
were you disappointed let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter I'm
at how not to draw thanks for watching
for your gaming and entertainment news
keep it gamespot
you